[Music]
Cheeta
scripters con-artists flimflammers
hucksters scammers mountebanks there are
as many financial frauds as there are
names for the people who perpetrate them
but here are five of the most popular
methods of parting a victim from their
money and how you can protect yourself
[Music]
in 1920 Charles Ponzi had an amazing
investment opportunity for New
Englanders guaranteeing a 50 percent
return in just 45 days on something
having to do with mail order coupons
incredible try unbelievable there
actually were no returns
Ponzi was just using new investment
dollars to pay back the previous
investors eventually the scheme fell
apart
Ponzi ended up owing 7 million dollars
and spent 14 years in jail ever since
then anytime a money manager uses new
investments to pay returns on previous
investments it's known as a Ponzi scheme
the most famous example was perpetrated
by Bernie Madoff who ran a high-level
Ponzi scheme for 20 years
that bilked investors out of somewhere
between 10 and 20 billion dollars with a
B before accepting an investment
opportunity you should look up a
broker's background and complaint
history on FINRA's broker check org and
you can request written evidence that
the investment professional is a sworn
fiduciary a close cousin to the Ponzi
scheme is the pyramid scheme say someone
offers you a no-fail way to make money
just by joining their organization for
$100 fee your job is then to find the
new recruits each pave you their hundred
dollar sign up fee 10% of which you give
to the person who signed you up if you
manage to sign of 10 people you just
made nine hundred dollars from their
$100 investment and in each of those ten
people find 10 people you get another
$900 for doing absolutely nothing and so
on and so on like a Ponzi scheme there
is no actual investment all returns come
from finding new investors and when
those run out the whole thing
says leaving the people at the bottom of
the pyramid with nothing this may sound
a bit like a multi-level marketing
company but in a landmark 1979 ruling
the Federal Trade Commission decided
that Amway was not a pyramid scheme
because distributors did actually have
to sell products to make money if a
business seems to stress recruitment
over sales that may be a red flag so
before getting involved in an MLM ask
your contact for information on the
success ratios of new members and how
the company makes its profits made
infamous in movies like boiler room and
wolf of Wall Street the pump and dump
scam is when an organization
artificially inflates the value of a
stock that they already own a lot of
usually by aggressive cold calling spam
emails and sometimes even fake news
reports when enough suckers have bought
in the scammer sells all their shares of
the inflated price sending the price
tumbling back down and wiping out most
people's investments getting rich quick
on the stock market is incredibly rare
if someone tells you they have a hot
stock tip or they know what the next big
thing is going to be ask yourself why
they would share this valuable
information with you imagine getting a
phone call from the IRS informing you
that you owe additional taxes that must
be paid immediately or a warrant will go
out for your arrest maybe they even tell
you that police are already in route to
your house but if you all cleared up
with a quick wire transfer of a thousand
dollars many people are so rattled by a
phone call like this and so confused by
tax laws that they'd rather go along
with it than risk making the IRS angry
but there are certain things the IRS
will never do they will never contact
you by phone or email first you'll
always get a letter
they will never demand payment in a
specific form and they will never
threaten to have local law enforcement
arrest you for not complying if you get
this phone call and are feeling
uncertain you should just call the IRS
directly to check if the request is real
hello mr. Wilson this is Joyce from your
state bank and I'm calling because we
suspect an unauthorized transaction on
your account Oh No
before we continue I just need some
information to verify that I'm speaking
the real Philip Olsen sure my birthday
is in my social security number is and
my mother's maiden name is how's that I
mean yeah that'll do hello hello
sometimes the easiest way for a scammer
to get your personal info is to just
call you up and ask for it they might
already know some things about you like
your address or your bank and just need
you to fill in the blanks under the
guise of confirming your identity the
digital version of this is known as
phishing where the scammer sends out
emails disguised to look like they're
from trusted sources these emails
typically contain a link that brings the
victim to an imposter website where
they're asked to enter account details
like passwords or credit card numbers
whether it's a phone call or an email or
a text message you should never give
your information to someone who contacts
you it's always safer to contact the
company yourself by calling their
official phone number or navigating to
their website directly typically if an
individual or organization is on the
level they won't have any problem with
you verifying their identity or looking
into their track record they should
welcome it and of course we'd all love
to get rich overnight and scammers know
it the best defense is remembering the
old adage if something sounds too good
to be true it probably is and that's our
two cents
do you have first-hand experience with
financial frauds are there any others we
didn't talk about that you think people
should be aware of sound off in the
comments
you